what is this you'll see okay it's
beautiful no you are beautiful I have a
surprise for you
remember it's the same per second we had
on our first day it's like a fairy tale
[Music]
I just want to make you so much you
don't have to I want to this feels
incredible it was so close to having a
full-on orgasm just from penetration me
too
let's climax at the same time one two
three
that's my butthole dude oh that's my
diet
no that's my other thing I can't believe
we had sex five times in a row and we
climax together every single time sex is
so easy sorry about that
okay did you get close at all hmm but at
least what you did it it's over yeah
yeah I did it how about that check that
off the list
[Music]